when Little Tokyo today because there's
a Pikachu hanging around here somewhere
there's a lot of people plan maybe I'll
ask them to see where I can find them
you guys seen it
Pikachu the servers were up I saw
Pikachu two seconds ago is there up
finally I'm good I'm trying to find it
this dankey to Stella
there's supposed to be here but we don't
defeat at you four units Pikachu milk
I mean I neither cycle
Oh
I did I said hey this is so good I'm
just gonna raise your rent
yeah the Pokemon girl came out like four
days ago we decided to delay the next
video we're working on in the meantime
put up a Pokemon go video ASAP keep in
mind there was a day where we used to
turn on videos in like four or five days
our strategy in order to make a good
video that's quick is to try to not rely
too much on visual effects we're not
going to worry too much about like a
storyline it's just going to be like a
collection of jokes and funny things and
funny ideas so we're gonna see how this
goes I never fought them through all the
way maybe 25 years old it's old is me oh
[ __ ] oh no I got underwear older than
yeah this looks pretty cool he's got a
black shirt and it's open and there's
the shoes yeah that's the one I use in
black gloves okay now the I guess the
difference would be I'd have to get some
spiky gel if I really wanted it like ah
so your hair as is it's totally fine
okay I can do anything for Sam and Nico
not me I've just heard lots of people
are walking into cars
while there when you catch a Pokemon you
can give that Pokemon professor one turn
gives you back a candy for the program I
give them candy
yeah and feed that can adhere Pokemon
the level off and then no crystal meth
pokemon crystal that is downtown
there's a lot of places that are really
cool and the only so I can tell you like
six the minimum the first hat we saw it
looked almost perfect grant was a little
short if we can't find anything else it
could work
push aside any of this that noise that
buzzing noise always unnerved me I'm
afraid of doors to begin with action yes
good tease a pony huh yeah okay there's
a little bit that badass to it you know
it's like yeah well the [ __ ] grind up
you know okay okay right yeah
can we give you a cup from upstairs no
not gonna get this stuff to people I'm
gonna drink it myself it actually did
[ __ ] it good oh [ __ ] it's like one thing
after another to the next one let's try
that plate
so it's 48 for the Dylan what are you I
got a call Jake no Jake is an answering
so I must make a call these are much
nicer
yeah house a lot more that's a good
difference yeah yeah the first guy we
talk to in this way she only still 12
just hang around long enough they'll
start bringing the price down or the
quantity then it's gonna come with you
know you said qualms about Pokemon
rights and how they were treated till I
started doing it and I realized it
doesn't matter with a Pokemon think
because it's so fun electing every
single one
everyone's going through those Charizard
everyone's going for those Wartortle you
know but me I get those giggling I get
those sparrows dude dude I've won zero
gym battles because all I have is
Diggler I don't like to think about that
I love my sparrows dude and not spar as
pizza that's different shout-out though
you know I'm just trying to get out
there trying to catch my Pokemon try not
to get hit by cars I chose a squirtle
because I'm the only cool one in here
squirtle is dope so don't tell my mom is
this going on the Internet start trying
when I was in seventh grade and I never
thought I'd make it this far
mbu's hole come on candies he's really
good I can't stop eating
they sneeze your brain alright so we're
going to check out little tokus it's one
of the hottest Pokemon going spots from
what I hear people were popping lures
Pokemon a flock in there like like mad
see that's a pokeball player right there
watch them
I personally have to catch all the
Pokemon mmm it was this gooey squirtle
in there anything and I think she was
born too early you don't actually have
it slip out of your hand we'll get a
shot specifically for the slip ready
what scene went great is the best one of
the day didn't it go save yourselves or
kind of like actor sort of I just I just
liked I just see like independent stuff
right now I am working on putting a
Sandshrew into this scene right over
here
what I did was I actually jumped on to
Google here typed in Pokemon 3d models
her OBJ's well basically my goal for
Sanchar here not to make it look super
realistic but to make it look like
augmented reality that you see in
Pokemon go but just a little bit better
so he already came with textures and
everything is great save him some time
and in addition that he's already rigged
and what that means is when you have a
character that's rigged you can actually
animate them how obviously fit saves a
lot of time I'm using 3ds max to do the
3d modeling and the rendering using boo
you to track scene and I'm using After
Effects to composite all that there's a
few special people we'd like to thank
you may have heard their names before
because they are a longtime supporters
Calvin kingdon great guy still great
going strong
John Welch from the GPL Thunder Bunch
yes the way man is so much a one-man
Thunder buns also we have Brian Winnett
from mayhem Park featured frequently in
her videos
Adam J Hilley he's a cool guy it's
your games thank you so much for your
support Adam our classic so Simmons hero
still don't understand the meaning of
that one soso is hero like he's a hero
he's still so so a lot to ask so so what
his actual name is in our next hangout
anyways guys thank you so much for your
support
and to all the rest of you guys for our
patrons as well thank you so much means
the world to us keeps us doing what we
want to do keeps us making cool videos
so when I see you guys so so know it's
so nice of you because it's so fun
collecting every single one that's what
matters
that's all that matters that and being
the very best like no one ever was I
mean that's my real test to train them
is my cause so I'm just going to travel
across the land searching far and wide
and each Pokemon will understand the
power that's inside Pokemon
I will be right back goddamn good
smoothie hit good I'm drinking this I'm
drinking this prop when it's done